morning what what are you doing in a
20-17 environment that's actually gonna
help you sell more homes bring more
awareness build your business build your
brand what were those strategies what
are those implications jab jab jab right
hook and the Thank You economy are both
still very underutilized by the market
people continue to put out content that
is in high percentage in their best
interests and not in the value of the
end user the number one shift that
everybody has to do in this room is
understand the following statement and
understand it cold not just shake your
head when you hear the words coming out
of my mouth
the quicker you understand in this room
that you are a media company comma real
estate agent real estate software
provider whatever you may be I know that
I am a media company tamo
and agency CEO a wine retailer once you
make that shift everything changes 11
years ago nothing that we talked about
in society existed not Netflix not
YouTube not smartphones not Facebook
zero if you are not digitally native you
will die and what I mean by that is
nothing you will die there like you'll
go directly out of business it's just
the people that are are gonna take your
business the world changes and the
biggest part that I'm worried about is
the world is changing in a much bigger
way that you and/or I realize this is
about a binary decision of are you
understanding how important digital is
or are you not and more importantly
making your actions
map your words thank you there are you
ruin my life how so because I didn't
video until a year ago yes I'm now about
35 a month and so their whole world
another video online and you do the
other man care if I want to hire an army
of people yes where would you is how
would you start first you need to be
educated so the first thing out there 5
hours a day do that because then when
you list it or you put it out on
LinkedIn or wherever you put it you'll
know what you're looking for the problem
that people make is they go oh I'm not
gonna hire 24 year old kid to do this
for me but they've no [ __ ] idea you
don't have if you don't have any idea
you don't know what to look for you
don't know if you're getting ripped off
if it's effective or not so educate
yourself and then very simply there's
unlimited places to get people there's
job listings for social media everywhere
in the world is that is that a
Craigslist thing or yeah I would I
literally would put in social media job
listings like on Google and you would
find four hundred things okay alright
thank you so thank you're welcome
morning hi and something I've changed my
life
thank you your content I met more than
quadrupled my income my perspective on
things the way that I teach agents it
all comes from you thank you so much I'm
gonna cry it has literally changed my
life
amazing I'm so grateful for this
opportunity thank you so much that means
the world to me congratulations much
thanks for all you do can we do like yes
yes take care of yourself are you losing
belief or you just wish it was happening
faster well then you need to buck up and
be more patient yeah yeah
entrepreneurship is a lifestyle not a
tactic it's forever there's ups there's
downs you know there's a quote I always
say that entrepreneurships like UFC
everybody loses like you're a young
woman like you're gonna have many more
at-bats being hungry and wanting
to win is very important but all that
ambition needs to be equally balanced
with patience and patience is hard more
patience thank you man I can't even tell
you
thank you brother I'm getting married in
a month you are congrats on seems like
you're probably more excited to me I'm
like I'm not a I feel like I can't hear
you honey
go ahead I'm listening to your questions
so how do you leave ego at the door I
don't I just uh
you had an Australian guy right who gave
you [ __ ] for undercutting his wine sales
yes right and you're like oh to be on
his show and then you went on his show
yes he has to be on my show and I put
over yes you oh I put him on my show
even bigger right dude negativity has no
value absolutely so like ego is
different than a grudge okay okay got it
three a grudge is negative to me an ego
is positive [ __ ] look at Fat Joe now
like yeah he's positive right now that
was fun let's say you know what I'm
gonna eliminate all obstacles put all
ego and pride aside and let me just try
the non ego route and and see how this
working so far we're platinum on the
sing go going to double platinum yeah
yeah magical miracle pill that seems to
be working yeah it happens my man Gary
thank you much love you so stay well
take care yourself good luck to you
our home video
it's a weird life but it's so flattering
yeah like people always like oh do you
hate it I'm like hate it it's like the
nicest thing ever like people like you
enough to be excited to take a picture
with you it's the greatest and I'm huge
with 40 year old dudes 10 are markers
they're just waiting for the [ __ ]
alarm man have your attention please may
I have your attention please
the San Francisco Fire Department has
investigate alarm and has declared so
Falls one two three four five six seven
nine ten yes okay probably around this
level one two three four five six seven
nine ten I never say my biggest advice
right now for real estate agents jumping
into social media whether they're in the
101 phase or the 201 phase is to take it
seriously this is a binary game this is
not about a tactic this isn't me saying
use hashtags on Instagram or Facebook
live matters or pay attention to
snapchat this is you either understand
that your customers attention is in
these spaces or you don't you either
believe in the digital revolution or you
don't it's a one in zero game and so I
think my biggest advice would be get
into it deep
it's so much great of course
I'll make a magic you moving back was I
had to have it made ahead are ya I'm
making magic I'm making magic you
weren't back was there's no inspiration
in retroaction you has been I'm moving
faster you stay is stagnant I had to
have it made it happen
yeah I'm
I think two steps ahead of me is loving
peace of quick release you best double
your bet big day obviously the Apple
announcement been sitting on that for a
little while it is what a peltro will I
am joined reality series plate of the
apps I love this I love the whole way
it's a big position why do they get
LinkedIn I don't oh oh wait careful this
picture me after season one it's gonna
be hey be much Gary Vee show hey super
excited you know obviously spent the
last six or seven years eight years nine
years passing on opportunities to do
television shows and other shows and so
finally found the one that I thought
made sense for for me
couple speeches couple business
opportunity speeding an investor meeting
you know vaynermedia Gary Vee Bainer
capital
just live in my life yeah don't play it
safe you know I'm gonna make a lane no
you got one person wrong you've seen
anything
they broke no fade away no no fade away